yes yes no no no no I don't believe it
this can't here we go there's more Oh
talk about how should there be more no I
thought I prayed to your Lord Matthew I
thought we had a deal
Matthew why do you do this okay
how's it goin brother paw we're playing
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] all right
here we go
we're gonna do level four and we're
gonna [ __ ] company that bar you rode
with Burt yes look it's so nice and calm
look at me slide ooh oh I feel so happy
oh it's so nice ah it warns my spirit
and feel I'm a I feel so nice I don't
think we're supposed to go this way I
bet Santa Claus is over here let's go
yay Oh for [ __ ] sake [ __ ] sake pass
his puffy [ __ ] there we go Eric
Nam a feet dance table okay it's okay
we just started all right don't go in
okay it's okay we just started this is
just um it's okay it's okay it's okay
it's just a game games can't hurt me all
right this one is gonna drop this one's
gonna drop that one's gonna drop
Oh what how does that even make any
[ __ ] sense on the spectrum of sense
Ness it's again it's just a game
you just got to keep a positive attitude
here we go
look how positive I am I'm positive that
this game will [ __ ] cause me to go
insane that that thing is gonna go up I
know it as much as I am a duck I know
that thing is gonna go up but uh well
what do you know what what do you know
what maybe sometimes you're lucky in
that we're gonna go up here I don't know
why how am I expected to go through that
yeah okay okay we're good we're good
hi
gonna go through this [ __ ] oh when he
goes up go up
he's going up but what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
see this part is easy we got this [ __ ]
in a bag [ __ ] in the bag [ __ ] everyone's
bag
[ __ ] you please [ __ ] cheap-ass
[ __ ] go up suck oh I can walk
on them oh my god that changes
everything is that ah
he's doing ah oh I can just walk on him
ah didn't faked it up he's gonna go up
go up
oh my god minecraft is a video game
going alright we're walking on this
[ __ ] my name's Jeff laughs it'll
be Rob and just a fun tanja blob or
Robin II a day that's corroborate is
Imran yeah [ __ ] yeah what
I tried at the end it doesn't even
matter what did I say what did I say box
oh look you think that was luck
you haven't seen [ __ ] on my skills man
I'm so good at games okay
checkpoint we got a [ __ ] check for us
we got a [ __ ] check boy that's what
I'm talking about
this is Gunther it's good they're from
adventure time I gotcha
give me kiss yeah that's right goon sir
[ __ ] Oh for [ __ ] sake what are you oh
good day young miss well [ __ ] you I took
a nap and now this ice wall is here and
I cannot pass it
can you go east to an igloo and get me
some fish okay great come back when you
have the fish I cannot stand your
fabulous dress young miss it just be
careful
iris around here it can fall on my head
alright got it
I usually don't trust snowballs with
[ __ ] machetes on their head but I'm
gonna make an exception
yes alright what do you want a [ __ ]
oh oh I got the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] this
game why does this game hate me I don't
trust this oh god the [ __ ] can
jump on ice what kind of [ __ ] beer is
this ah go ahead go dah
good job wait talk about yes calm down
all right it's okay you know what we did
pretty [ __ ] good
are you ready I can't hear you here we
go
this bet come on oh god okay
bad my mistake run run run run
yeah let's write Oh God ah you died
[ __ ] oh god - yes ha ha alright you got
your [ __ ] fish I got me my strength
back now let me destroy this wall for
you beauty
oh stop it you're free tomorrow evening
yeah I never I never dated a walk god
what is he doing oh my goodness that hit
was just too much I will not be able to
make it sir I mean miss you go I will
just rest here for a while
no all right there's a sleigh the [ __ ]
is this tank me my sweet oh god okay so
you see we can do this what the [ __ ] is
that I don't need to go with it what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you then this is how we do it
nope [ __ ] you this is how we party
moving with your body come on everybody
yeah yeah get up up and [ __ ] how many
times as I swore this we're gonna [ __ ]
yes this is [ __ ] amazing this is
where we need the slate isn't it yeah
damn it can we jump up oh [ __ ] I think
we need the slate
goddammit all right what are you kidding
me
come on Slade tonight we dine in Hell
what the [ __ ] was this is the greatest
game of all time Matthew McConaughey
would rate this game nine out of nine
[ __ ] you then oh my god
yeah here we go here we go [ __ ] it's
coming come here [ __ ] that's right bit
oh god what the [ __ ] I was sliding I
have a good feeling though I think we
could actually like there's a small
[ __ ] percentage amending javelin up I
have so much anger it's [ __ ]
incredible I love it
all right ladies what is that sound I
think I'm too slow here that [ __ ] was
that okay I'm just assuming that I'm
sucking a lot of penis right now oh oh
oh oh no oh no oh no we were so close
we've done we died eighty times eighty
times are you kidding me Oh God
okay oh god no come back come back god
damn it this is the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this
is the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] one yes yes yes yes
yes flawless flawless flawless like my
shade legs flawless like my the [ __ ] are
you waiting for
alright jump Gunther jump come check
stuff I jump too early I jump to our lay
it's okay I'm just gonna do fart noises
from now on I hope you don't mind
look I don't even have a shirt anymore
that's how much I died
where is it all right it's coming back
the rage is back I don't like it that oh
you [ __ ] god yeah I know I can't
touch the floor
I [ __ ] though I can't touch the floor
suck a dick suck a dick come here [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you jump I'll [ __ ] it fast I
don't not have dad I'm this close to
race critic do you know I'll [ __ ] toe
satis I spread it [ __ ] cold
come on blah blah go jump what the [ __ ]
was that I'm gonna get a [ __ ] heart
attack gonna die on this life thing this
is will be my final thing I do bruss
it's been good it's been a good run man
but this is [ __ ] it for me I don't
know what to do anymore I swear to Allah
in the heavens name in the god
[ __ ] ass licking piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I suppose to do it
I just spontaneously combust and I'm
sorry if I don't know what the [ __ ] I
was supposed to do oh yes how how how
what are you telling me no touching the
floor near the science will make the
blue guy spawn Oh
Oh touching
oh my [ __ ] dicks oh my [ __ ] dick
oh oh oh my god I can't believe it I
literally can't believe it I'm so
[ __ ] happy what happens now I'm happy
look at me
oh [ __ ] oh god you got to go up fly on
the wings of duck come on fly high house
come on how do I get up No
the checkpoint is right there okay Bruce
I know when I'm defeated and that's
that's where we're gonna end it all
right rest we can tried so hard and got
so far but in the end it doesn't even
matter thank you guys for watching I
love playing games for you I really
appreciate your watching and I'll see
you in the next video stay awesome I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you I'm gonna [ __ ]
stop